[THEME MUSIC]
So there's an
amazing documentary
called "Flight from Death,"
in which an expert introduces
the concept of terror
management theory.
Now, terror management theory
was coined by Ernest Becker
to describe the ways in which
the human being responds
to the unbearable awareness
of the mortal coil,
like the fact that
we know that we
are born with a death sentence.
And to use our life
with an agitation
that we have to
respond to in some kind
of either creative or
destructive capacity.
And that is known as terror
management theory-- how
we manage the terror of
creation and mortality.
And there's a line in the
film that's really poignant.
One of the guys says
the explicit awareness
that you're a breathing piece
of defecating meat destined
to die, and ultimately,
no more significant
than a lizard or a potato
is not especially uplifting.
And you know, it really
sets up the premise.
It's like what do we do, right?
We're a creature that can
ponder the infinite, that
can contemplate
infinity, that can
ponder the origins of the
ten trillion atoms that
make us a sentient
mind that were cooked
in the furnaces of stars
billions of years ago,
ultimately-- and
at the same time,
look in the mirror
every day and witness
our own decay over time.
The human situation is absurd.
There's something romantic in
the ways in which we respond
to this angst in our
poems and in our artistry.
But nonetheless,
there's a sadness
inherent to just our humanness.
There's a sadness
to that awareness.
[THEME MUSIC]